Oh YUM
it's not a game
[Music]
Westworld season two penultimate episode
vanishing point this is an odd one for
me and I did something that I very
rarely do I slept on it I'm not
recording this right after having seen
it I'm actually not even recording at
the morning after it's been almost a
full 24 hours since I've seen that
episode and I'm still not entirely sure
what I think of it and that part of that
might have to do with ultimately it may
depend on how the final episode wraps up
I came into this episode not necessarily
knowing what to expect I was not
expecting it to top or even meet last
week's episode because last week's
episode was just a phenomenal piece of
work but I hadn't even been expecting so
I I really tried to make a point of not
trying to hold this up to the standard
of that previous episode
unfortunately the episode kind of begs
the comparison because it's doing
something very similar taking a
character that we don't know much about
honestly in terms of their if is
backstory and giving us more context
giving us more details giving us more of
their story and and first of all
repeating that for the man in black does
unfortunately big the comparison to kick
suya the previous episode even more
which I don't think is a good idea
because it doesn't measure up to that
but in addition this is a character who
I'm not sure actually benefits from the
additional information that's granted
now there's nothing wrong with what we
learn about him it's not a case of like
well that doesn't make sense that
doesn't jibe with what I know they did
it wrong it's nothing like that it's
just more of a case of I don't think I
learned very much new information
about him pretty much everything that we
see about his life outside the park I'm
not I'm not gonna go so far as to say oh
I guess that I didn't but it's all
incredibly logical it all tracks it's
all very oh yeah that's pretty much what
I would have thought yeah okay he's yeah
he's he tries to put on a much nicer
face he has a marriage that is kind of a
mess he you know has relationships with
people that are weird and awkward his
daughter probably doesn't know him as
well as she thinks and in the flashback
at least and all of that I kind of go I
kind of just drunk and go yeah it's it's
that's about what I figured it's not
impossible to have information be
unsurprising but still have it work like
the the episode that gave us the
backstory on
kingpin the first season of daredevil
that worked and on paper it was doing
something similar I think the difference
there was that kingpin himself as a as a
character was such a mover and shaker
that getting a better sense of where he
was coming from could give you a better
sense of maybe what he was gonna do next
I don't think the added context that we
got on the man in black actually gives
us any better of a sense of him than we
already had like overall as a character
so like part of the thing is that he he
has an interesting dynamic with a number
of characters including his daughter
especially when when we're in the the
update the the the current time frame as
as opposed to the flashback but I think
where it all falls apart for me as an
episode and and an execution is his
extended thing sitting down and talking
doing what he thinks is his sleeping
wife and on paper it's not about singing
it's actually kind of you know kind of
fitting he talks when he thinks she's
know
listening but he just kind of lays out
exactly what we were already seeing or
or that was already being indicated and
what was the very logical extension that
the that the monster he is in the park
is the real him it's not you know an act
he puts on to let off steam that's his
true nature coming to the forefront
that's I mean I don't know about anybody
else that's kind of what I've suspected
from the beginning so to have him lay it
out in this extended thing it it brought
back memories of season one but like in
a bad way cuz season one did a bit more
of this let's sit down and talk about
the theme let's make the subtext text
and season two hasn't done that nearly
as much and I've appreciated season two
for that so having it go back on that
sort of story and that method of
storytelling again kind of doesn't
really work for me
and as far as the the other elements at
play you know his wife you know it's not
uninteresting but it's yeah it's about
what I would have expected his daughter
it's interesting to see the contrast
between how she behaved towards him then
and how she does now but and and the
other thing is that him at spoilers duh
you should know this him shooting his
daughter wasn't surprising like it felt
inevitable but not in a way that like I
was going oh god no here comes you know
here comes the other shoe more just like
it yeah I saw that coming I think I
think it would have worked better if it
had been more sudden and I don't just
mean the moment he did kind of shoot her
in a sudden moment but given that we
watched him shoot all the security guys
first believing them to be hosts and we
see it's very clear that he is not in a
clear mental state of mind and so him
then shooting his daughter too it
doesn't come as a big surprise I think I
think it would play better if that had
been
much more sudden had much less build-up
and then in his you know standing over
the body starting to talk about you've
overplayed your hand forward I saw
through this having him say it after he
shoots her that could have been like oh
my God look how far gone he is as
opposed to playing that before the
shooting which just makes the shooting
feel like okay when are we gonna get to
it because that's clearly what they're
building to so I think they I think they
did those in the opposite order that
they should have been done done in in
terms of trying to get maximum impact
out of that and I do cuz I do on paper
find his spiraling down to be
interesting he is so obsessed with this
game that may or may not actually exist
in any real or at least in the way that
he believes it to exist that he sees
everything through that lens and he is
so blinded by filtering everything
through how does this fit the game that
he does something horrible and I think
that can be really powerful I just think
the way that they chose to actually good
it doesn't quite get there and the final
moment I'm not really gonna judge on
because it's not clear whether he is
digging out of his arm a like a port
like Bernard has to be them which would
indicate that he's a host or if he's
digging around looking for one because
he hopes he's a host and not the real
thing we don't get a clear indicator of
which is the case there and that's maybe
part of why I'm trying not to be overly
judgy about this because there are
things yet to be played out moving off
of that and getting on to the other
stuff um I brought up Renard so he works
pretty well I thought it was interesting
watching him kind of really fight
against Ford and to see Ford really just
so calmly be really certain about what's
gonna happen there's always something
really under cuz I don't know if I could
call Ford a villain because I because I
still don't really know what his
goal or objectives are in this but he's
he's a he's a disquieting presence and
there's something about a character like
that who's just totally calm and who no
matter what they seize you that's what
was always going to happen I did tell
you and there's just something really
unsettling about that and he sells that
very well and on that I think the
segment I like best
the thing that I loved was Teddy indoors
now I called fairly early in this season
that there was going to be some kind of
confrontation between the two of them I
called that they were gonna come to
blows and that Teddy was gonna kill her
obviously that's not what happened but
they did basically kind of have a
confrontation so and I kind of I like
that I like what it turns out that I'm
half right so like I was right that the
two of them were gonna come to a head
but how it played out from that I was
not right so I get that validation of oh
I'm kind of you know figuring stuff out
while still getting to have some element
of surprise not being like yeah called
it so that's that's fun for me when it
went strikes just that balance the way
this one did and the way that plays out
is really good and I figured where it
was going at the point when Teddy says
I'll protect you until I die and that's
what I thought he's gonna kill himself
and the window between when I thought
that when he did it was short enough
that it held it held on to the impact in
a way that the man in black Tony's
daughter failed to do and I also really
liked divorces reaction to that because
initially is there it's like a state of
shock and watching the full realization
of what it is that has just happened
that she has just seen that she caused
to just crash into her it's really well
done it's a really well put together
moment we only get a little bit of Maeve
but I did I big grin on my face when you
can see she's starting to mess with
settings oh she's gonna wreck shop and
I'm gonna be so happy so yeah
unfortunately the the big main thrust of
this episode is the part that I have the
most issues with but again even those
issues I do want to stick an Asterix on
because depending on how well the last
episode sticks the landing it might
redeem some of this and it might give
more meaning to why it was necessary to
show this stuff because taken as an
episode onto itself like I said I don't
I didn't feel like I learned much I
didn't feel like what they showed me was
as revelatory as the show seemed to
think it was so you know that's that's
kind of a shame but maybe it'll be
redeemed of the last episode aside from
that part a lot of stuff I liked so a
little bit of a mixed bag but still good
it didn't totally fall apart what were
your thoughts on the latest episode of
Westworld whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it support me on patreon baby
I'd love it there's other stuff to do
such as like and subscribe and follow me
on Twitter and buy t-shirt etc etc leaks
where all this stuff is down in the
description and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]